I don't intend to be anybody but Joe
Biden that's who I am okay Brandon why
is the price of of of agricultural
products when I go to the store why is
it higher
guess what
they're closing those plants because
they have coveted
by the way everybody internationally
uses Bill back better now when I use the
phrase initially people looked at me
like build back better
probably starting within the next uh two
to three months as we get things shovels
and grounds I will downsize your your
face with a shovel I could take I'm
gonna get in real trouble
[Applause]
hey hey I'm your favorite internet
politics talk show host Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it's September 15
2022. we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and plays TV subscribe tap the
notification Bell share the videos
spread the word okay uh we have a Reuben
report locals Community Q a for you
today uh but I wanted to do two things
up top we usually do one thing up top on
Thursdays when we're doing the Q a so
that I can get right to it and the
questions are a great mix of personal
and political and cultural and
everything else today as always uh but
today I said we have to do both of these
stories because it's just so patently
ridiculous uh what happened yesterday
first off Rand Paul just bashing uh Dr
fauci Lord fauci over the head with
using his own words it was just
spectacular but real quick I want to
talk to you guys about this uh this
Governor DeSantis situation and sending
the plain full two planes full actually
of illegal aliens people who are not
legal members of the United States who
cross the border illegally thanks to the
Biden Administration well Governor
DeSantis is sending them as he promised
to do he's sending them to Martha's
Vineyard here's a little video from Fox
and two planes full of illegal migrants
just landed on Martha's Vineyard
apparently they were sent there by
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis Fox News
digital got this video showing the
migrants landing on the ritzy Island
where President Obama has a summer home
and the clintons hold their ritzy
fundraisers there and it's where Bill
Gates takes his vacations
I wonder how they'll greet their new
neighbors
okay so this is just so perfect because
first off DeSantis said he was gonna do
it and he did it that's number one he is
a man of his word number two people are
very very angry at DeSantis and they're
very angry at the governor of Texas
Abbott and a couple other uh uh
Governors like in Arizona who are doing
similar things with buses this one was
very dramatic because it was two planes
but they're very angry at them be there
they're exacerbating the situation
they're sending people to DC the same
people who want DC to be a sanctuary
City and no person's illegal and blah
blah blah then they start showing them
to Martha's Vineyard and the libs the
lefties the media people they're all
crumbling they are all crumbling and
freaking out and crying right now
because they're going to Martha's
Vineyard Martha's Vineyard I've never
been there it's one of the most
exclusive places in the entire United
States uh we've got Barack Obama's home
I think we have a picture of that that's
Barack Obama's mansion He got that after
being president being president only
pays you about two hundred thousand
dollars a year I think but somehow he
400 is it 400 I thought it was 200 I
guess they're given a little more but
I'm pretty sure on a 400 000 year salary
you shouldn't be allowed you shouldn't
be able to afford that that thing it's a
12 million dollar house 8 200 square
feet
we understand that his daughters who are
24 and 21 don't live there anymore so
he's got plenty of room there so you'd
think now that evil Ron DeSantis has
sent the refugees there you'd think that
Obama maybe he could put up a couple
tents outside maybe give somebody a
guest room or something so let's just
see if the rhetoric matches the action
with the Democrats so it's just a great
move by DeSantis and I just wanted to
hit it up top and of course there CNN
literally this morning compared this to
the to the Holocaust as always I mean
these people are just liars and buffoons
and just remember whether you think it's
a political Ploy or not or it's a little
bit of a stunt or anything else no state
has to keep any illegal person in that
state it is the job of the federal
government it is one of their few jobs
to protect the Border they will not do
that well then congrats uh blue States
it's your Governors that are going to
bring these people in and create
Sanctuary cities and everything else so
I'm very proud today to be a Floridian
uh let me talk to you about gender cell
real quick and then get into this Rand
Paul Dr fauci thing which was just nuts
yesterday uh you know I've been using
Jandy cell for quite a while now and it
makes me feel and look so good during
the show each morning can you tell I'm
glowing I've told you a lot about
janucell my absolute favorite luxury
skin care well ladies and gentlemen how
does 25 Virginia sell sound geniusella
is celebrating the rollout of their
personal shopper concierge service by
offering their best sellers at 25 a
piece not only is it a ridiculous
discount but you'll get a personal
shopper you can reach out to via text
cell phone or email from the convenience
of your couch no login and no passwords
here's Teresa from Orland Park Illinois
genucel definitely makes me more
confident I've been using it for a while
now and it does help with my crow's feet
it tightens the skin making wrinkles a
lot less noticeable I have to hide it
from my husband because he likes it too
she should just buy one for her husband
25 for the most effective Skin Care in
the world to take care of all your skin
care needs and with its immediate
effects guaranteed results in as little
as 12 hours of your money back go to
genucel.com Dave right now that's
g-e-n-u-c-u-c-e-l.com slash Dave uh
every most popular package is
automatically upgraded to free shipping
geniusell.com
David now back to me okay so yesterday
we had another one of these Senate
hearings where they're trying to figure
out what went wrong with covid and
mostly it's a lot of blathering and
nonsense and nothing ever comes of any
of this stuff but I have shown you over
the course of the last year a couple
times
when Rand Paul in particular he is
particularly good at this Ted Cruz is
also excellent at it but Rand Paul who
of course is a doctor he is an
ophthalmologist uh he has often often
taken Dr fauci down a notch or two so
they got into to a big Skirmish the
first part was about natural immunity
and fauci was not ready because Rand
Paul uh well he brought the receipts
but she's had the flu for 14 days should
she get a flu shot well no if she got
the flu for 14 days she's as protected
as anybody can be because the best
vaccination is to get infected yourself
this is an ongoing question and you know
we've had ever-evolving opinions from
you Dr fauci currently antibody surveys
show that 80 percent of children
approximately 80 percent of children
have had covid and yet there are no
guidelines coming from you or anybody in
the government to take into account
their naturally acquired immunity one of
the things that we also know after
looking at this for two to three years
uh is that the mortality from covet is
very similar if not less than than
influenza
so when we look at this we wonder
you know why you seem to really Embrace
basic Immunology back in 2004 and how
you or why you seem to reject it now
well I don't reject basic Immunology
Senator Reuters fact check looked at
that
and said fauci's 2004 comments do not
contradict his pandemic actually words
don't lie if you look at the words
behind me we could go over them a little
bit at a time she doesn't need it
because the most potent vaccination is
getting infected yourself you're trying
to tell us that kids need a third or a
fourth vaccine are you including the
variability or the variable of previous
infection in the studies no you're not
because when you have approved vaccines
in recent times and the Committees that
have improved it for children don't
report anything on hospitalization or
death or transmission they only report
that if you give them the jab they'll
make antibodies and you can give kids
hundreds of Jabs and they'll make
antibodies every time but that does not
prove efficacy so what you're doing is
denying the very fundamental premise of
Immunology that previous infection does
provide some sort sort of immunity it's
not in any of your studies almost none
of your studies from the CDC or from the
government have the variable of whether
or not you've been previously infected
okay so I know that was a bit long but I
hope you understood why we played you
the full thing and we have one more clip
for you Rand Paul knows what he's
talking about but it's not just that he
knows what he's talking about he's using
bauchi's own words against him and then
of course fauci oh but the but Reuters
fact checked it and he's like uh dude
this is exactly what you said back in
2004 that previous infection creates the
best line of defense right like that's
it we all know it and it has nothing to
do with any of the policies that fauci
put forth right they weren't saying okay
you don't have to get the shot so you
can go back to school if you've been
infected they were never saying any of
that so he just really he just nailed
him to the wall it's just absolutely
perfect fauci should be ashamed to be
seen in public at this point uh and
what's really interesting is now the
second part here because they continue a
little bit more on this but now uh Rand
Paul really gets to the heart of this
which is why were they pushing these
vaccines on everybody what kind of
connections do the people at NIH
CDC and fauci himself and perhaps the
media people what kind of connections
are there with the pharmaceutical
corporations who sponsor all the news
shows as we've shown you uh and who are
making crazy profits by endlessly
injecting children with experimental
vaccines that aren't quite vaccines that
you can now get everybody doing every
year uh just whether they've had covet
or not do you think there might be a
little corruption here you decline Ai
and people decry vaccine hesitancy it's
coming from the gobbledygook that you
give us you're not paying attention to
the science the very basic science is
that previous infection provides a level
of immunity if you ignore that in your
studies if you don't present that in
your committees you're not being
truthful or honest with US senator if I
might respond I have never ever denied
fundamental Immunology in fact I wrote
the chapter and the textbook of medicine
any of the guidelines for vaccines do
any of the guidelines for vaccines from
the government include previous
infection as something to base your
decision making all with vaccines and
furthermore we've been asking you and
you refuse to answer whether anybody on
the vaccine committees gets royalties
from the pharmaceutical companies I
asked you last time and what was your
response we don't have to tell you right
we've demanded them through Freedom of
Information Act and what have you said
we're we're not going to tell you but I
tell you this when we get in charge
we're going to change the rules and you
will have to divulge where you get your
royalties from from what companies and
if anybody in the committee has a
conflict of interest we're going to
learn about it I promise
okay what you mean know what you're
talking about say it clearly and
forcefully I love that ending there when
we get back in power because it is very
likely that the Republicans will get the
house it is a little less likely but I
think very possible that they'll get the
Senate and then fauci could be in a lot
of trouble a lot of trouble because what
if the people that were making all these
decisions were making tons of money on
this because they had stock in these
companies and it probably is the case it
probably just is and why is it that the
guy who wrote the chapter in the book on
Immunology why is it that he didn't
include anything on previous infection
why is it that having gotten covid has
nothing to do with whether they would
want kids going to schools or not the
point is I know it's like nonsensical to
even talk about covet anymore but when
we have these brief moments when some of
the [ __ ] is is exposed and and these
people are taken down a notch I think
it's worth noting and I want to just put
a pin in this one because hopefully the
Republicans will take back the house and
the Senate and then they'll drag fauci
out again with some teeth behind it with
some teeth going man you could be in a
lot of trouble now unless you really
start telling us the truth now the funny
thing about all of this is that again
and you know I like to give CNN credit
when there's something remotely sane on
CNN well Democrat activist Jake Tapper
who was you know four lockdowns and four
masking and four vaccines and everything
else he's kind of even coming around on
that this stuff doesn't work it just
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
there's a vaccine there if you want to
require the vaccine require the vaccine
but the masking is damaging
psychologically emotionally and
educationally for these kids
okay so I could have shown you more with
Gupta there but the point is that Tapper
even when he gets it he doesn't really
get it because it's like if you want to
force them to vaccinate then force them
to vaccinate it's like no doesn't work
uh it's against civil liberties uh it's
against uh privacy and all of those
things
um but his point is that masking them is
really bad so all of this it's like it's
starting to happen the pushback is
starting to happen obviously kids are
back at school it's the fall now they're
not gonna stop they're going to keep
pushing and pushing you know they're we
we know right it's the fall now and the
weather in the Northeast especially it's
going to get colder there'll be more
covid blah blah blah
you guys got it you got it sometimes I'm
doing the show and I'm thinking my
audience is too smart why do I even have
to talk to them I could just sit up here
and stare at the screen and you can we
could just you know I could not every
now and again and you guys we at the end
we'd be like all right good show good
show uh all right let me talk to you
about fast growing trees then we'll get
to the Q a uh I don't know about you
guys but I spend a ton of time making my
house feel like home indoors and out
that's why I love
fastgrowingtrees.com whether you're
looking to add some privacy shade or
natural beauty to your yard fast-growing
trees has in-house experts ready to help
you make the right selection with
growing and Care advice available 24 7.
the experts at fast growing trees curate
thousands of plants so you can find the
perfect fit for your specific climate
location it needs you don't have to
drive around to nurseries and big
gardening centers fast-growing trees
makes it easy to order online and your
plants are shipped to your door in one
to two days I love fast growing trees
when David and I were remodeling our
home this summer we brought in a couple
new trees we have some uh what do we got
we got a mango we got a avocado and a
few more I cannot recommend them enough
you guys go to fastgrowingtrees.com
Reuben and you'll get 15 off your entire
order now through October 15th get 50
off at fastgrowingtrees.com
reubenfastcore increase
uh all right here we go
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
Kathy says how is Mr burrito he looks
like an easy going baby is he getting
into a routine so yes Justin is a little
over a month now I call him Mr burrito
because he is a good eater so he's got a
little weight on him I think he's in
like the 80th percentile and height and
weight he's going to be a big kid that's
what it's looking like right now
and when we wrap them up and swaddle him
I'm not very good at the swaddle you
guys know about the swaddle I've talked
about it before they literally wrap
children up like a burrito almost like a
straight jacket
um and uh it basically so they can't
like poke themselves in the eye or
scratch their face or whatever but it
just kind of there's a there's a
soothingness to it that they're kind of
wrapped in and tight uh but he's doing
great he's doing great and since I've
been back to work my morning routine and
you guys are seeing this on locals where
I'm posting pictures
um you know I sit with him for usually
about a half hour in the morning uh
sometimes that's feeding depending on
what his schedule is at that time but
that's just kind of me him and Clyde on
the couch just relax and try to get a
nice spot on the couch by the Sun so he
gets a little Sun you want kids to get a
little bit of of indirect sunlight so
that they don't get jaundice a little uh
little vitamin D is good for the kids
and and for the adults I suppose and uh
and then we try to take a walk in the
morning and then I'm busy all day long
so then I kind of don't see him much
till really around dinner time we throw
them in the docket it's like little
little soft little box kind of thing
that you can just kind of put on the
table and he can just kind of lay there
and make some sounds
Etc et cetera but it's been good it's
been good it's all good I'm a dad weird
Lawrence says whenever I applied for a
job I had to be interviewed to see if I
understood what was required for the
position when I enlisted in the military
I had to take a test to see what sort of
Duties I could qualify to do shouldn't
candidates for office have to pass some
sort of test concerning the
responsibilities of the job and have a
working knowledge of the Constitution
they are swearing to defend well great
question first off thank you for your
service
um yeah you know it does seem like an
awful
a lot of politicians today and I would
say this across the aisle have no idea
what they are doing in Congress like
what their duties are to the people and
especially I would say this definitely
goes more to the Democrats especially
the younger Democrats they seemingly
have no desire to or intention to uh
defend the Constitution which is what
they are sworn to do is to defend the
Constitution from enemies right and I
would argue in many cases they have
become the enemies whether it is their
Alliance of corporate and political
power which some might say is a type of
fascism whether it is trampling on the
first amendment by pushing on big tech
companies to silence people there's a
huge amount of other things that they
have done like and that's the problem
and I think that's the problem that as
we expose they will get more and more
hysterical you know if you take a whole
bunch of young politicians say the AOC
Ohan Omar Squad crowd and then you know
you take the sort of decrepit crew that
left with the Democrats Pelosi and
Schumer and everything else and and the
basic idea that they run on is that
everything is bad that the 1619 project
in America was founded on racism that
that's what our true history is that we
are systemically racist that we are an
evil patriarchy all of these things well
then why would you defend the
Constitution of the United States so I
don't think AOC has any intention of
defending the Constitution of the United
States as a matter of fact in that
ridiculously silly puff piece that GQ
did on her last week she basically said
one of the reasons she might not run for
president is because she wouldn't have
unlimited power right she would have
checks and balances and it's like that
tells you an awful lot about these
people that they want power more than
anything else so yes should there be a
basic test wouldn't that be something if
they just had like a one-page test for
anyone that got voted into Congress or
the Senate and it could be basic stuff
I'm talking multiple choice Scantron old
school number two pencil like just basic
Civics how many many branches of
government how many senators are there
you know what is federalism like some
basic stuff I would I would bet about
sixty percent of them would fail maybe
even more
Harry says if the progressive old Dave
appeared today what would he think of
the modern left's ideas would he try to
defend them or would he be shocked and
horrified by what has what his party has
become I mean
I can only answer that as new day the
new Dave's a little better than old Dave
which is that I saw the light like old
Dave credit to old Dave he was he was a
little misguided at first but he came
around like old Dave saw it I think
honestly I I don't think it would
surprise me how crazy it's gotten like
that's what I was worried about I felt
that there was nothing stopping any of
it that that there was a um a cultish
attitude with it and that reality didn't
matter and none of this would surprise
me so you know if you go back even to we
talked about it a week or two ago you go
back to my first interview with Jordan
Peterson from 2016 and he's talking
about this this law bill c-16 in Canada
they're going to potentially jail or
find People based on gender pronouns and
like there was a little bit of me even
though I was still in my wake up process
that was actually before the why I left
the lat video so I was still I still
considered myself on the left there was
a little bit of me that was like no this
this is a little nuts like they wouldn't
do this in Western societies but but
there was another part of me and I think
this was the driving part which is why I
was so outspoken all the years
which was nothing's going to stop these
people that's why I was always
challenging the Liberals because I felt
and I still do this is why I'm always
talking about Bill Maher and why I'm
looking forward to talking to him next
week it's like there was a challenge to
the to the good liberals and and believe
it or not even though I know most of you
guys are conservative or libertarian or
whatever like there are good liberals
and there were good liberals and JFK was
a liberal right and uh you know
there was a chance there was a chance to
stop the thing but liberalism collapsed
the Liberals collapsed and that that was
very sad for me so I think I would be
horrified I I don't think I would be
totally shocked
um but I think most of us if if you just
flash back to say even six years ago
right it's not that long ago I think
most of us would be like man this this
weird wacky state is still uh on like
it's still happening right now like
something something ain't right I think
we can all agree on with that Amy Says
have you had any weird dreams about
being a parent or about your son since
Justin has been born
um yeah I've had like some yeah yeah I
don't want to get into like all the
specifics of them but I've definitely my
dreams have felt when I've woken up you
know you sometimes you wake up and
you're like oh that that dream meant
something and it was obvious a lot of
times your dreams can be sort of
amorphous you can't quite put them
together or you just kind of go back to
sleep or you maybe should think about it
but you just wanna you just want to roll
over and close your eyes I've had more
dreams I would say that like I've woke
up and been like oh that's obvious
um but more even I think related to my
childhood so there's obviously something
going on there we're maybe thinking a
little bit more about my own childhood
and uh now trying to be a father and all
that kind of stuff uh Candace says did
you hear about evil Sheila cool getting
raided and Patty giggins the civilian
oversight of the civilian oversight
Mission I'm curious what your thoughts
are since you protested at Sheila's home
so Sheila cool for those of you that are
not playing inside or baseball she was
one of the Los Angeles County
administrators
of the five-person board who decided to
make she was the deciding vote when they
decided to close outdoor eating after
they had opened up some stuff and things
were getting a little bit better in Los
Angeles she was the deciding vote to
close outdoor eating and then from the
vote
she went because it wasn't going to kick
in for 24 hours she went to her favorite
Italian restaurant in Santa Monica and
ate at the restaurant having just voted
to close all the restaurants so there
was a massive protest outside of her
house a few days later I didn't really
like the idea of protesting at someone's
home I believe people have a right to
privacy that's where they happened to do
it and I was so enraged at the time that
I did go and there were hundreds of
people there and as I often say and the
media frames that these were all scary
Trump supporters and mean Republicans
and Nazis it was like it was basically
all liberals these were these were Los
Angeles actors and lighting people and
just people who had been mugged by
reality and wanted to keep their
businesses open or whatever else so I
took a bunch of the guys and we went to
her house that is where in front of
Sheila Cool's house I will never forget
it that is where we all signed the
recall for Gavin Newsom I signed it uh a
guy came up to me he was a fan he let me
uh on the paper he had to do it by hand
and if your pen actually touch the line
above or the line below it would
discount they would get rid of your
signature so a guy came over he said
Dave you can I'd be honored if you
signed it on my back and I signed the
thing right there anyway what's going on
with her right now apparently her house
was raided there are some questions as
to whether she was doing Shady deals
with contracts related to the city and
that you know the city has to do bid
contracts if things are over I believe
five hundred thousand dollars so she
signed somebody that she knew to do a
contract for 494 000. sounds a little
shady doesn't it anyway I don't know a
tremendous amount about it and I don't
even want to really focus on Los Angeles
or California too much suffice to say I
have a feeling she did something shady
and either way she does not deserve that
job or respect or anything else City
says not a question just want you to
know I'm praying for your meeting with
Bill Maher oh well
thanks listen
I think you guys know how I'm gonna do
it and as I said they do it he often
smokes weed during the interview I am
not going to smoke weed with Bill Maher
but they did ask what my drink of choice
is I asked for my class Azul Reposado on
the rocks and we'll look we'll have a
drink and we'll talk it out we'll talk
it out my intention is not to get him I
hope his intention is not to get me I
hope they'll release it pretty quickly I
hope they don't do any editing and
we look this is somebody who I've
admired for most of my life who I think
is a decent guy I think for the most
part he's fighting the good fight even
if he's still coming to some of the
wrong conclusions so it's going to be
good like how often do those
conversations get to happen and I I also
would say that I hope that it will be
just one of the first you know I hope
that he will then come on this show
maybe we can do it live in Miami and
maybe we can do it in front of an
audience and let's just continue
continue that conversation and let's see
what happens like like if we were both
let's say we were
90 in agreement say five years ago so
okay so now I've gone to the right and
let's say he's kind of stayed this way
but the left has gone off the deep end
it's like well okay let's let's keep
having this conversation over time let's
see which is right is it right that
Florida is run better than California
like I think it's pretty obvious is it
right that high taxes and big government
programs don't work I think I'm right on
that
um we can have the abortion conversation
we can have any conversation I think if
we could try to do it time over time two
people who actually respect each other
or they have an understanding of where
they came from and all of that stuff and
the fact that I was a fan of his and
when I started doing stand-up in 98
really almost more than The Tonight Show
I wanted to get on politically incorrect
because that sort of fit more within the
types of things that I was doing
um and his stand-up specials have been
spectacular even if I disagree with some
of the stuff on them now and I interned
actually for Politically Incorrect in
around 1999 for a week they did a week's
worth of shows in Brooklyn uh and I
interned for Politically Incorrect that
I'm sure he doesn't know that so I'll
bring that up and all right so we'll see
what happens that's all I got to say
about that uh Char says Dave could you
talk about the fact that Miami is now
the safest city in America how did that
happen at a time when crime has
skyrocketed uh our once beautiful cities
and suburbs so yes not only is Miami now
the safest city in the United States and
that's despite all of the people that
come to South Beach and were coming
during covet and yes there was some
violence in South Beach people were
coming here and getting drunk and
Hooligans and all of that stuff but we
are governed by good people uh Francis
Suarez who is the mayor of Miami who
I've interviewed before and we're going
to interview them at the local studio in
a couple weeks uh he well he's a
republican he believes in Law and Order
he is right now he's got this initiative
to try to reduce the homeless population
in Miami to zero I don't know if that's
actually possible I truly get it to zero
but you don't see the tents you don't
see the transients you don't see the
drug you see here you know what you do
see you do see a decent amount of cops
around and it's not like cops like
they're hunting down people to find
people that are not doing bad things and
put them in jail it's like you get a
sense of oh this is a place of Law and
Order I live in the suburbs
of Miami in a small area here and we
have a small police force I mentioned on
the show the other day there hasn't been
a home robbery in my area in 12 years
you the the streets are clean and
another thing that's beautiful about
Miami is there is so much construction
right now and this is happening all over
Florida but I live here in Miami so I
can talk specifically about that there
is so much construction because they
don't have all the red tape and
regulations around building so all these
people are flocking here one of the
problems that Florida has right now and
this is a legit problem that DeSantis is
going to have to work on and all the
Mayors are going to have to work on is
when you do it right when you build the
promised land you know what happens an
awful lot of people want to come to the
promised land and then these people have
money and resources so then housing
prices start going up and then the
people who were the OG Floridians they
are having trouble getting houses now
that's a serious real issue that I would
love to work with the mayor on if
there's anything I can do to help
um but the point is that there is very
little crime here in Florida as a whole
but specifically my Emmy it is
flourishing how are we doing all of this
without having income tax I would have
paid money to get in you know it's like
you know what it's if you bring in good
people with the right ideas uh Suarez
actually wrote a op-ed I think it was in
Wall Street Journal
so it was at the end of August I read it
right when I got back just what his
guiding philosophies are which is that
the government's not supposed to do
everything we're going to create the
conditions for you to figure out a way
to live the way you want to live and
it's working man it is absolutely
working and on top of everything else I
saw that Florida was also voted or Miami
is the most fit city in the United
States
we all gotta get to the gym today you
know what we're gonna have a Reuben
report out today because we live in the
fittest city in the United States uh
snow baby says what are you looking
forward most to teaching your sons
um
you know I've been thinking about this a
little bit sort of in the in the context
of the show like when I sit there with
Justin it's like when you bring a child
into this world like that is a blank
canvas you know like when he's just
sitting there and he's kind of looking
at you and he's looking around and he's
you know he's still not like fully
locking eyes yet but like he's just kind
of looking at the world they say they
can't they can't they see more shapes
yet it's not it's unclear whether babies
immediately see colors so we do a lot of
high contrast images with them and we've
just started giving him like putting a
mirror in front of him so he can see his
reflection a little bit
but one of the things that I think about
when I'm looking at him is like relative
to what I do here for a living right
which is so much of what we talk about
is related to How uh say State educators
are treating children when it comes to
gender and all these things
um whether you know I try to get the
right ideas across to you guys like now
I have a deeper responsibility to this
kid
right we have a deeper responsibility to
to Justin and his brother who's on the
way it's like I want these kids to know
that there is something in the world
that is true that there is right and
wrong that that reality exists and all
of those things and how will I make sure
that all of the bad ideas that I'm
constantly fighting on this show don't
get
don't infect him I don't know it's going
to be difficult it'll be a little bit
easier because we'll we'll hopefully
have the means to have him in the right
school or be homeschooled uh it'll be a
little bit easier because we have a good
Community around us and good families
and things like that but it's not going
to be easy the culture War comes for
everybody right like it really comes for
everybody you don't know how they can
get your kids you know there are plenty
of parents that probably do everything
right you know whatever right means
basically right that still the kid could
get hooked on fentanyl or whatever it
might be so I I've been thinking about
that a lot like how how do you protect
this child without over protecting them
and also make sure that that the evil
stuff out there doesn't get them
TBD TBD Elizabeth says a lot of active
activists are pushing for puberty
blockers on children and some are even
saying that everyone should be placed on
them until they can decide which gender
they want to be I know that sounds nuts
but that's actually true how can we put
a stop to this kind of insanity should
the parental rights education bill in
Florida be adopted in other states or is
that still enough look that's a start
that is a start but it is not enough so
first off of course every state should
model the don't say gay bill which has
nothing to do with being gay and simply
that you do not want six-year-olds being
taught anything about sexuality or
gender by state Educators and state
Educators and especially if they can
keep that information private from the
parents just imagine I mean I thought
about this so now Justin's six years old
he's in first grade imagine if I found
out that actually for three months there
was a teacher talking to him about
gender or sexuality maybe calling him
Justine instead of Justin and I didn't
know about that
I might kill that person that's where
we're at right so unless you don't want
these people killed and I mean this
somewhat flippingly
um
like it's they want to abuse children
they want to abuse children that is
abuse I don't mean that as overt sexual
abuse but it is an abuse of a child and
you can start by doing some of the stuff
legislatively but really what you need
to do is everyone needs to understand
these issues clearly and not let their
kids be part of this if this is
happening at a school if it's happening
wherever it might be happening if it's
happening at a church or a synagogue or
in the basketball league or any of the
nonsense you must be willing to stand up
and tell your kids what is true and not
put them in in danger from these things
because this absolutely is danger what
do you think the world is going to be
like when we when we're being run right
now we're being run by a bunch of
geriatric lunatics who are just trying
to hold on to something they should have
given away a long time ago or never had
a right to hold for so long what do you
think is going to happen when the say
millennial generation or even below the
millennial the Zoomers or even below
that when this the eight-year-old of
today when they're in charge and they
think back to being jabbed with things
that we find out they shouldn't have
been jabbed with and they think back to
being put in front of tick tock to be
brainwashed with gender nonsense and
abused by their teachers and now they're
in charge you think they might be a
little pissed off at the old people I
think so I think so Joe said Joe says
aside from your own which books do you
recommend everyone read they want to get
a better better understanding of current
affairs and how we got here you know one
book I absolutely recommend I've read it
at least three times and it is an
incredible framing of America and the
right ideas and why this thing is
precious and an experiment and we better
not give it up is uh it's still the best
Hope by Dennis Prager Dennis has a new
book coming out right in a couple weeks
I think we're going to have Dennis on
yeah in a couple weeks to promote his
new book but that's what year was that
still the best hope can we get a year on
that I think it's probably about 10
years ago or so maybe even more actually
let's let's check on that but it's just
a great uh Dennis has a way not only of
speaking but of writing where he can get
complex ideas out in a very very clean
mature way and I just love the title
still the best hope
and that's what I'm always talking about
here we still got hope that was pretty
good I said about a decade ago 10 Years
2013 pretty good uh so I would start
with that if you haven't read it and
then uh and then go from there uh lady
broad says is Rumble stock available to
purchase so I I don't know because I'm
obviously uh I'm Consulting with Rumble
I can't get I don't know exactly what
I'm allowed to say or not allowed to say
or anything else but it is public
knowledge that Rumble through a spack
which is a special purchase acquisition
company uh known as it's listed in
NASDAQ right now A cfvi as of tomorrow
this is public it will be listed as rum
r-u-m pretty cool rum we'll have some
Mojitos and it will be Rumble uh so I
can't I'm not giving you any advice I'm
not here to give anyone Financial advice
certainly I obviously believe in the
company I love the idea that free speech
in essence will be going public that is
that is pretty great
um and I'm going to New York City now
next week so more on that soon so so
cool stuff is happening but don't take
that as any sort of financial advice
whatsoever you know talk to your
financial advisor I guess don't listen
to Jim Cramer on CNBC or whatever
channel that clown is on
um but it is very exciting there there
are good things happening what we have
needed this entire time was a public
company to come in and fight you know it
was one thing to have little companies
trying it and that's why I'm so proud
that we we vocals was just this little
idea that I had and we started building
it and it was just for the locals
community so I could have my own
Community right and then we started
spawning it off to other people and then
suddenly we had something and it was
doing well and we got good investors and
we had great people in Tech behind it
and it's still advancing right I did a
live stream yesterday
just for the local community and our our
live stream now off the phone is as
sharp as Instagram and rolls the same
way and and it's and it's awesome and
it's just one of the features that we're
laying out but then we thought okay well
we're not strong enough alone to beat
big Tech how about we join with Rumble
and rumble's got an awesome cloud
service Beyond just the the sort of
front-end YouTube side of things and now
that's going public and that means that
the people the people can get in on it
so it is pretty awesome so don't take
that as Financial advice uh they'll
obviously be more over the next week or
so but uh I'm very excited about that
Brian says what is your favorite holiday
by far Thanksgiving Thanksgiving by far
you know I love the idea of sort of an
American secular holiday that everyone
regardless of religion or Creed or
origin everyone at least hopefully
celebrates Thanksgiving a time to be
thankful for what America is and you
know hopefully you're sitting around a
table with at least a couple people that
you love or like and you're eating some
great food I am extremely blessed to be
around a lot of great chefs as as you
guys know David is a great chef but his
mom and his sister uh sister-in-law like
these are these are incredible chefs so
we we make oh we fried a turkey one year
we do we just do awesome things it's a
couple days of cooking and drinking good
wine and enjoying ourselves and just you
know we go around the table we talk
about what we're thankful for uh but I
really love it because it's the thing
that everyone does as opposed to not
everybody celebrates Christmas or not
everybody celebrates Hanukkah or not
everybody celebrates is it Diwali is
that the Indian holiday Diwali I think
it's Diwali yeah I got a yes on that not
everyone celebrates these things but but
Thanksgiving is what America is all
about right this Melting Pot of people
from every background every walk of
Earth
can come together and celebrate and be
thankful you know a little humbleness in
these crazy times we live in is probably
good uh Beth says as someone who's been
looking for a new job using job sites
like uh indeed and Linkedin I'm sickened
by how many companies are asking for
pronouns and Vac vax status do you think
a platform like locals would ever
compete in that space and feature
non-woke companies who believe in
Freedom and who don't care which of the
20 new pronouns someone is so first off
before I get to the what we're going to
try to do with locals the idea that all
of these companies have been infected
with this I mean it's dangerous right
and and it goes back to one of the
questions earlier about like what would
I want to protect my children from it
would be the pronoun craziness it would
be a world that you have to say whether
you are vaccinated or not to get a job I
mean it's it's sick it's sick and
twisted but it's here right so like we
have to acknowledge that it is here it
has infected these companies link
LinkedIn is not going to turn around on
that imagine if at LinkedIn they just
suddenly had a meeting they were like
boy you know maybe this pronoun stuff is
kind of stupid and I don't know why we
put it in and let's get rid of it guys
even if everyone at the board there
agreed the base the activist base the
Twitter Roddy the trolls in the Box
would all turn on them so they become
they become hostages of things that they
often don't even believe in they Usher
it in they don't realize how bad it is
and then they become hostages but
fortunately you know go woke and go
broke and that's why a lot of these
companies are really struggling
as for locals and would we do something
like that yeah we're trying to figure
out like we're really trying to re-build
the internet we would love to figure out
a way that your Local's home page will
be sort of your new Facebook and guess
what you'll own everything and we're not
going to data mine it we're figuring out
instant messaging so you can message not
just the creators but you can message
each other uh we were thinking about
something related to job boards like it
all it all just takes a little bit of
time it just takes a little bit of time
but I'm telling you these guys are
working hard we got the right people
there and uh stay tuned uh Antoinette
says you said you had help planned for
when Justin was born do you have help
planned for his brother I can't imagine
how hard life is about to become praying
for you all so yeah so we have we have
baby two coming basically well October
14th is the due date but I suppose he
could show up at any point maybe if
you're listening or if the surrogates
listening right now stay as long as you
can enjoy yourself in there it's nice
and warm temperature controlled
um but uh yeah yeah it's crazy like you
know our life has changed significantly
obviously in these last couple weeks and
mostly in great ways that I can't even
fully explain uh but that we're about to
do it again even just the idea of like
going to the hospital again and that
whole experience again and the bris
again and just like all the stuff again
it's like here we go again I suppose
deja vu all over again
um but we do have a baby nurse who's
absolutely wonderful and you know
fortunately having some help and you
know because we've had David's mom and
my parents have been here and I've
mentioned that my sister just gave birth
with her third uh so you know we've had
people around here to help out and uh my
team around here helps out Daphne has
been very helpful uh you know with
swaddling and other things
um so yeah it's it's good and you know
you just I think in life you just kind
of move forward I think if I've done one
thing well probably it's just that you
move forward you don't even know exactly
what you're doing the whole time right
you can't really think about it too much
like I think if I had thought about it
too much boy adding two kids to the
equation and I'm so busy and I'm doing
all the things that I want to do and you
know I've mentioned many times that when
I was on tour with Jordan
he was talking about how most people
to live a fully actualized life need the
experience of being a parent it always
makes the point not everybody there of
course are people on the margins that
can find other things to make their
lives fully fulfilled most people need
that I think it's possible I think I was
sort of like an edge case on that like
my life had an awful lot of meeting a
month ago I have put so much into this
I've built companies I have good friends
I'm in a good relationship like
I was pretty fulfilled but I know there
is a deeper fulfillment right now and
and a deeper one even coming
um but you just you just move forward
you just say hey I'm going to do
something and if you just do it I don't
know maybe maybe that's all that life's
all about really uh CS says is Trump
going to show up in your studio in
person that'd be awesome Phoenix are we
working on that
I got a thumbs up we are working on
getting Donald J Trump to the Local's
office in Miami he doesn't do a lot of
like I'll come to you kind of things
this is more of a you gonna come to me
kind of thing
um so I guess we could try to get over
there look obviously there's a lot of
energy there's always a lot of energy
around Trump there's an awful lot right
now between the Mar-A-Lago raid between
him deciding whether or not he's going
to run and you know that's why it's also
like I haven't spent too much time
talking about 2024 because it's like
until we have a sense of what Trump's
going to do the rest of it is just
nonsense right DeSantis has an election
coming here in November he's obviously
going to crush it
I don't know that I even want him to run
you know we've discussed it many times I
think you can make arguments either way
it's like on one hand I want this guy to
just solidify Florida and he loves
Florida and let's be The Shining Beacon
for the world and in some ways it's it's
a sad truth but the state that you live
in matters more than the country I know
that that doesn't sound right
and of course I don't mean that to be
anti-American in any way I love this
country I wish this country could live
up to the American ideals that it often
did until these last couple years
um but the state you live in has has
Paramount importance so the idea that
you know we'd export to santis unless
everything has been taken care of here
they figure out a success a secession
plan uh and and all of those things not
not secede from the union I mean someone
else come in after him a succession plan
um you know these are all the things
that you have to think about so uh but
yes I would gladly interview Trump I
would even do it at Mar-A-Lago if
they're not gonna but but they'd be
bugging me they'd be bugging me like
they bug everybody over there gosh darn
it uh reminder guys like our videos
subscribe rumble.com Ruben report love
seeing those Rumble numbers going up uh
part three of my interview with investor
Vivek ramaswamy is up right now the full
thing's up at locals uh absolutely
ad-free and the Friday a round table
Extravaganza is back tomorrow we've got
Libby Emmons from post millennial we've
got Viva Frye from viva Barnes law Viva
who just he fled Canada and he lives in
the Free State of Florida very exciting
and the third guest TBD to be decided
we'll know within the hour I leave you
with the cold clothes have a great
Thursday everybody see you tomorrow
he's finally beat Pharma
that's so weird we beat farmer this year
we beat farmer this year what in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] it didn't happen that
didn't happen [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
sorry never happened never happened it
never happened it never happened it's
never happened and it didn't happen just
no way it has never happened never
happened never happened never happened
ridiculous [ __ ] it never happened it
never happened never happened that has
not happened I think it ever happened
never happened never happening that
didn't happen and it still never
happened it didn't happen come on man is
that monkey conscious